hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game that was played last year
in December in defeated World rapid
Championship sorry the blitz
championship this from the blitz section
uh the game was overlooked by me as it
happened in the final round and we were
pretty much only uh following what was
happening will will he will Magnus be
able to win in the final round or not if
he will be able to overtake up the
satrov and as Magnus had 15 points going
into the final round both uh Daniel and
Jan had 13 and a half points uh none of
them could catch up to Magnus but this
game really is a brilliant see you guys
will enjoy it uh if you want to check
out the actual footage of the game it's
available on chess base India's Channel
I will put a link to it in the
description below uh it's really
something that you would uh you you
definitely want to watch it's only some
seven and a half minutes long and it
will definitely be worth your time but I
will try to
properly uh dissect what happened in
between the moves uh so let's check it
out Yani she uh one for the players who
might become the world classical
Champion if he defeats Dean liveren this
year against Daniel dubov none of them
really need introduction so let's dive
straight into it uh nepo wit opens with
E4 we have C5 by Daniel Daniel goes for
the Sicilian Defense Knight F3 E6 and
now Pawn to D4 we have captors captures
and Knight to F6 attacking the four Pawn
nepo defense and not Knight the seasick
we enter the timana variation of the
Sicilian and now Knight D to B5 going
after this D6 square and this is where
the fun really begins now the standard
ideas here are D6 preventing Knight to
D6 and also Bishop to B4 just spinning
that Knight and C3 but the Doom of goes
for Bishop to C5 sort of inviting Knight
to D6 and this doesn't come as a
surprise to nipple as all of these moves
were played fairly instantly he plays
Bishop to D6 with the check and now King
to E7 this is the main move in in the
uh in this line if you go King to f8
it's still playable but not as great
because Bishop King 37 comes with a
threat of just Bishop captures on D6 so
you are forcing white uh uh decide what
what happens here the problem with
capturing on D6 and yeah you might even
think this is great let's say captures
captures black will play Queen D7 and it
seems like black is perfectly fine but
look at this bishop F4 and there is no
good way to get out of this if if you
know if Queen captures Bishop capture
it's a good luck getting rid of this
bishop here it will paralyze your your
position for the rest of the game and
even if you play something like castles
the white will still just straight Play
Bishop to D6 and it's not much better
Rook to E8 you want to unpin but now
just F3 and now Knight at the B5 is
coming going after the C7 square and if
you play A6 then you weaken the dark
squares you play Knight A4 you go to B6
and again not much to be done here
Knight C6 Knight to B6 and you are stuck
with this bishop and Knight here pretty
much forever so that's why you have to
play King 7 here and of course both of
them know this nepo blitz is at Bishop
to F4 E5 now now there's a thread of
just Bishop captures on D6 but luckily
Knight to F5 check is available King to
f8 and Bishop back to G5 now pinning the
Knight here and here Bishop to B4 and
this is the first moment of the game
where nipple really starts thinking
about the position and uh it's not easy
the way to deal with this is that you
have to play Knight to E3 or you you can
play Queen to D3 or Bishop to D3 just
continuing development but Knight to E3
is considered strongest because you add
another Defender to the D5 Square you
really don't want to allow D5 and if
Queen to A5 going after the C3 Knight
you can even play Knight to C4 go after
the queen and if captures captures and
captures with check you bring the bishop
back and this is perfectly fine let's
say queen D4 F3 and white has a very
good game however in the game uh nepo
decided to go with Bishop to C4 and now
dubo strikes immediately in the center
with on the D5 and this is a straight
out of Pawn sacrifice which nepo will
accept only he will have to decide how
to accept this pawn and there are many
ways to accept the pawn you can play e
characters on D5 you can play Bishop
captures on D5 you can play Bishop
captures and F6 uh to remove one of the
Defenders now e captures on D5 is very
much uh playable now you give up the
Knight here white will capture the
Knight on C6 and now after the Queens
get traded off Queen captures throw
captures you will play B captures on C6
and okay nothing special happening here
but uh black uh well at least equalized
and is playing a position that he
prepared so here instead we have Bishop
captures on F6 Queen captures on F6 and
now Bishop captures on D5 so nepo wins a
clean Pawn but now Bishop captures an F5
e captures and not Queen captures on F5
there is a game that was played also in
the world Blitz Championship however in
2013 between Pavel ponkratov and Elder
Safari
uh that uh safarily won very nicely with
the black pieces uh but here we have
Rook to d8 now not allowing this bishop
to move and
um nipple again has to waste some time
and he spends a lot of time calculating
this it's not easy uh because uh you
can't really defend the Knight with your
queen or anything like that because once
the bishop captures if the queen
recaptures nothing is defending this
bishop so you have to be really careful
here uh nepo decides to go with A3 and
now the problem is although this is a
fine move Nepal has 55 seconds on the
clock whereas do both well over three
minutes so dubo pretty much played all
of his moves instantly Bishop to A5 and
now B4 and this is the first move of the
game where dubov spends a little time
thinking he's probably deciding on
Knight captures on B4 and it is possible
Knight captures 8 captures Bishop
captures and now you are threatening to
win back your piece you want some pawns
but the problem is white will just
castle and now after Bishop captures and
see three are going to play root
captures on A7 and that's it not much to
worry about here for white equal
material uh it's uh well not much for
either side so instead dubov keeps the
tension Bishop to B6 not even because
it's the best move maybe it is like the
engine says Bushman B6 and Knight
captures on B4 are pretty much the same
however it does require nepo to burn
more time and he plays castles here and
now uh nepo is down to 25 seconds and do
both well over two minutes and he plays
Bishop to D4 now the problem is Bishop
captures on C3 is coming you can't move
the Knight because of Bishop captures on
A1 and if you do nothing again if you
try to defend the Knight with the queen
then you of course black will just
remove the defender of the bishop and uh
black easily wins a piece here so after
Bishop to D4 now nepo immediately plays
Knight to the E4 attacks the queen queen
captures on F5 and now Bishop captures
on C6 very nicely done by nipple now
Bishop characters on A1 is impossible
due to Queen captures and d8 Checkmate
so okay dubo plays B captures in C6 and
now the problem is uh how do you how do
you play this uh nepo only with a few
seconds on the clock uh he played his
next move he had around five seconds on
the clock remaining and he played Queen
to D2 probably guarding the F2 Pawn uh
so it doesn't allow any Bishop captures
and F2 Rook captures on D2 action uh or
Rook captures on D1 because the queen
was on the one the problem is this was
not possible for dubov uh if you if you
just play Queen to D3 let's say this is
not possible if you play Bishop captures
on F2 uh just Rook captures and F2 and
now the black queen is hanging here what
nepo did not have time to calculate
after Queen to D3 is that after Queen to
C8 now okay you are threatening this but
uh and also Bishop captures and A1 is a
threat you can play Rook 8 to D1 and now
after Bishop captures and F2 Rook
captures and Rook captures on the 3 you
will have some compensation for the
queen like it's a it's a knight and Rook
against the queen but white should not
uh lose this by force uh however that's
a lot to calculate with a few seconds on
the clock Queen to D2 was played and now
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for duboff while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on realizing that C3
is never a real option and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
Queen captures an E4 yes in this series
time travel Nepal completely left the
Knight hanging on e4 uh probably
thinking that he can just win the piece
back by playing C3 then the bishop will
uh hang of course the bishop cannot move
but that's exactly what the bishop can
do if never plays C3 Bishop B6 guards
The Rook that's what nipple missed so
instead Rook 8 the E1 was played uh
sorry Rook 8 the E1 was played and now
just Queen to F5 getting the queen out
of Harm's Way with Ponte A4 and now
Ponte H5 now dubo will just push his H
Pawn and checkmated the white king or or
something C3 now attacking the bishop
but just Bishop back to B6 we have Queen
to E2 and Nepal was so annoyed here that
he blundered the piece like that that
the the little Pawn that he was
shuffling in his hands he uh
accidentally dropped him on the floor
then he picked picked it up dubo played
H4 with Ponte A5 Bishop to C7 and now
Queen to A6 we have H3 by Daniel and now
Queen captures on C6 but this move
wasn't really played never picked up the
queen and then the queen almost fell out
of his hand and then he tried wiggling
it a bit and by the time uh he you know
got a solid grip on the queen his time
ran out okay he plays the queen on C6
but it was basically in this uh
possession on move 27 that Yani pumping
she lost on time but also his possession
is just uh completely lost the problem
is now uh dubov can play pretty much
anything he can play H captors and G2
attack The Rook here and even after
Queen captures an F2 just to Rook H6 how
are you stopping Rook to G6 uh there's
really nothing if King H1 okay you
sidestep but now E4 and again there's no
defense against this so uh of course
terrible position and due to the
terrible position that's why uh Jan lost
on time after playing this queen
captures on C6 move and what a brilliant
brilliant preparation by by Daniel
it started very slowly like nipple of
course knew this line and he knew how to
play it very properly but after Bishop
to B4 here he started thinking he didn't
know the the exact correct way to treat
this he went for the bishop to C4 line
and then he just started burning time
massively which was enough uh you know
for it to culminate in this uh terrible
terrible error of uh moving the queen to
D2 here and just allowing Queen captures
and E4 uh so yeah as always Blitz is
Blitz is merciless you you have to know
your stuff especially if you play a
sharp line line like this and in a
classical game uh Nepal doesn't shy away
from from playing all sorts of crazy
lines and a classical dubo versus Yan
match would be uh something I mean it
would be it would resemble rapid and
Blitz only it would be absolutely
precise and it would be uh super
enjoyable to watch but uh you know here
yandere didn't have enough time to show
why why he is the world chair
Championship candidate and well he just
got destroyed by duboff yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it if you
want to see the actual footage like I
said some seven and a half minutes you
you will enjoy it uh thoroughly first
link in the description below do check
it out so thank you all uh for that I
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to friend D and I would like to thank
Deepak
Benjamin you young and Arun Kumar
arumugam for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day